welcome back to the rock stars I'm Erik
Bosse in Watchmen the upcoming HBO
series premiering October 20th will
further explore the fictional reality of
Alan Moore and Dave Gibbons
groundbreaking graphic novel which you
may have seen his ex nighters 2009 film
adaptation with a new story set a
generation later designed to continue to
make us feel real bad about the whole
concept of superheroes now you know
whether it's Watchmen for the boys good
luck I still have a spider-man mask and
it will always make me feel special but
what exactly is this Watchmen HBO series
all about how is it connected to what we
know about Watchmen why's being made now
and could Watchmen be the new high
concept must watch mythology series of
our times
HBO hope so okay this new series takes
place in a fictional 2019 34 years after
the events of the Moore and Gibbons
graphic novel that story was set in a
fictional 1985 in which Richard Nixon
having mused dr. Manhattan to win the
Vietnam War became a sort of forever
president bringing the u.s. closer and
closer to nuclear war with the Soviet
Union and Watchmen superheroes are being
assassinated by a mysterious assailant a
plot that turns out to be the spoiler
warning for the original Watchmen
orchestrated by Adrian Veidt
Ozymandias who stages a massive attack
on New York City with an alien tentacle
monster in order to force the US and
USSR to in their Cold War and work
together to defeat this common threat
even though it's based on lies now in a
Zack Snyder movie Ozymandias destroys
New York with a kind of nuclear blast
that he blames on dr. Manhattan the same
kind of uniting against a common enemy
peacemaking Gold both novel and film end
with the night listed vigilante at the
heart of it Rorschach getting blown to
bits by dr. Manhattan but not before
exposing this conspiracy by Meili in his
journal to a newspaper and on that
cliffhanger it leaves off this HBO
series picks up 34 years later but from
the graphic novel not so much the Snyder
film a shot and the Comic Con trailer
showed a drawing of the tentacle monster
meaning it exists in that version of
reality superheroes continued to be
mythologized but now in the form of TV
series like American superhero story
parody of American crime story on FX I
assume featuring the original og
Minutemen heroes like hooded justice in
the comedian so expector has aged into
an FBI agent now using her father's name
Laurie Blake played by Jean smart Adrian
Veidt has now played by Jeremy Irons who
according to shots of newspaper
headlines and trailers might be
considered dead by the public but he's
still very much alive watching from is
mansion homes and digging into brightly
colored cakes Rorschach's journal it
appears has gone on to inspire a cult
named the seventh Cavalry who wear
Rorschach style masks and released
anonymous style videos where they quote
Rorschach's famous line the seventh
Cavalry is a US Army regiment famous for
Custer's last stand
perhaps this cult sees Rorschach as
their Custer a martyr who died serving
some noble cause this cult has organized
a widespread home invasion attack on
police that has inspired the police led
by Don Johnson as Chief Judge Crawford
to wear masks to conceal their
identities and protect themselves and
their families
most of the cops were yellow masks but
in the trailer footage you can also see
some of them wearing like animal masks a
panda mask so now pretty much everyone
is wearing a mask where is the line
between hero vigilante and reflects all
kinds of social themes in America and
2019 that I can't wait to have screamed
at me from the comments section Regina
King stars as Angela a bar who also
masks herself Tim Blake Nelson plays
detective looking-glass it was a shinier
mask and a pass trailer he eats beans
right out of a can a reference to were
shacked doing that in his name Looking
Glass could be a nod to showrunner Damon
Lindelof spaz series lost in which the
Looking Glass was the name of one of the
Dharma stations of the island and Andrew
Howard is playing another masked crime
fighter named Red Scare now this series
is set in Tulsa Oklahoma which might
give us a clue about this world like
maybe after the New York attacks the
American population has decided to move
away from the coast some more inland
landlocked cities that are better
protected from external threats but
Tulsa as the setting also has some
historical significance according to the
trailer footage the series also appears
to be exploring the dark history of the
1921 Tulsa race riots in which the most
prosperous black community in the
country was fire bombed and destroyed
honestly it's one of the most horrific
episodes in US history that not nearly
enough people know about but again
watchmen takes place in a fictional
history one that in the graphic novel
begins with world war two but might go
back further in history to the 20s Louis
Gossett jr. plays will Reeves who might
have some connection to that history in
the present day this fictional history
Robert Redford has been president since
1992 Redford is playing himself as
president in the series in the original
Watchmen Nixon abolished presidential
term limits and for the series a
newspaper headline shown in the trailer
suggests that Redford will not seek
another term in this America by the way
has a flag with 51 stars because in the
graphic novel after defeating Vietnam
they made Vietnam the 51st state sorry
Washington DC in Puerto Rico
dr. Manhattan is also very much part of
this story after the events of the
original Watchmen he went off world
living on Mars making plans to
experiment with life in other dimensions
in this series there's a round-the-clock
video stream of dr. Manhattan on Mars
and parades for him back on earth in the
Zack Snyder film Manhattan allows
Ozymandias to turn him into this
worldwide pariah and scapegoat him for
the New York attack though in the
graphic novel he remains an impersonal
god figure whom some worship some just
don't trust the past trailer for this
series shows him returning to Earth
clothes though this is HBO they could
probably get away with that Snyder
full-frontal but it remains unclear what
role dr. Manhattan will play in this new
series assuming society becomes too
unstable he may just come down to
intervene but with President Robert
Redford not seeking another term perhaps
dr. Manhattan will run for the office I
don't see him wanting or needing that if
only to prevent some worse alternative
now the newest trailer also features
some familiar tech - Watchmen fans the
owl ship which was night-owls batwing
thing and angela is seen wearing night
owls eyepieces suggesting the character
could return to the series or maybe
Reeves is a collector hooking her up
with his gear also one shot shows Adrian
Veidt around some steampunky looking
chamber which some are saying looks like
a time machine maybe a kind of
teleporter or maybe it's a chamber that
recreates the conditions that created
dr. Manhattan Osmond is already views
himself as a superior being a natural
step for him would be to turn himself
into a god so what are you most looking
forward to with this watchmen series
comment down below with your thoughts
follow me on twitter and instagram at
leave us and subscribe to the new rock
stars for breakdowns and theories about
everything you love thank you for
joining me and let's just hope that 24/7
coverage of dr. Manhattan on Mars is
x-rated
you can see that thing from space
[Music]